[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in keeping with the holiday spirit
today's brief video will also touch on
the relationship
between harry potter and christmas more
specifically
i'm going to be questioning the
existence of a powerful fabled and
magical being
he's a man with a great long white beard
and unquestionable power
and it's not merlin or dumbledore it's
father christmas
aka santa claus first let's take a look
at who exactly father christmas is
at least from the perspective of our own
world father christmas
is the traditional english name for the
personification of christmas
although now known as a christmas gift
bringer and typically considered to be
synonymous with santa claus he was
originally part of a much older and
unrelated english folkloric tradition
the recognizably modern figure of the
english father christmas
developed in the late victorian period
but christmas had been personified for
centuries before then
so the idea of santa claus aka father
christmas as personification of
christmas
has existed for centuries and in more
modern times he has been adapted into
the jolly
fat white bearded red suit-wearing man
come christmas time
father christmas magically shoots
christmas presents down the chimneys
of houses worldwide spreading joy but
how can one man deliver so many presents
in just one night surely it must be
magic
which brings me to harry potter
throughout the harry potter books and
films
father christmas is mentioned a fair few
times in general his name is used in
much the same way
that modern people would use it to
describe someone jolly
fat bearded and prone to giving out
presents
however maybe there's more to his
existence in the magical world
maybe they know something that we don't
i wonder is a conventional
representation of santa claus real
in the harry potter universe father
christmas is either seen or mentioned
in a magical setting in the following
films chamber of secrets
goblet of fire order of the phoenix
deathly hallows
and fantastic beasts he pops up quite a
lot so
is he real the beauty of harry potter is
that in the world of magic anything is
possible
and the fact of the matter is that a man
traveling the world and delivering
presents to children
everywhere is well in the realm of
possibility for a world where there
isn't really
an impossible it's far-fetched but we've
seen voldemort achieve
pseudo-immortality by imbuing his soul
in objects minerva mcgonagall will
transfigure herself into a cat
albus stumbled or apparate and civil
tralani predict the future
a man traveling the world and delivering
billions of presents in a single night
sounds outlandish but i don't think that
it falls out of line that much with
these other feats
we know merlin existed in the harry
potter and an adaptation of nicholas
flamel
and many other notable figures from
folklore so
why not father christmas why not santa
claus i think santa claus is a wizard
think about it how could one man deliver
presents down the chimneys of homes
worldwide
oh i don't know how about the flu
network a network connecting chimneys
all over the magical world
as for the homes that don't have a
chimney santa is an ancient powerful
figure
and are more than confident that he
possesses the ability to operate
apparition involves basically
teleportation which would really come
into handy for a man with a task like
his
okay so what if someone sees him how is
he able to maintain anonymity
ever heard of a spell called obliviate
it wipes people's memories
i guess that leaves just one thing how
on earth does he deliver so many
presents in such a short amount of time
ever heard of a little thing called a
time turner if a wizard could take
control of the only limitation stopping
him from delivering these presents
time then it's not outlandish to say
that he could really deliver
all of those presents and how does he
keep his workshop hidden
concealment charms in addition to all of
the above points answer me this
who works for santa at his workshop
that's right elves
and we know elves to exist in the harry
potter universe i'd love to hear what
you guys think about this but i know one
thing for sure
in the magical world anything is
possible is santa real
or not let me know what you think in the
comment section below
until next time merry christmas you